مشاهدينا بالخبر العاجل وفق مراسله
الجزيره فان سفرات الانذار تدوي في هذه
اللحظات في الجليل
الغربي معنا الان من رام الله لواء واصف
عريقات الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك لواء واصف نريد ان نبدا بحجم الخسائر
في صفوف جنود وضباط قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اربعه في يوم واحد ليس العدد
الاكبر سجل سجل عدد اكبر من ذلك ولكن ايضا
تظل الحصيله مرتفعه يعني منذ ال 26 من
اكتوبر نتحدث عن
132 جنديا وضابطا كيف تقرا هذه الخسائر
الكبيره مقارنه بحروب
سابقه يعني خير من تحدث عن الخسائر في
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الجنرال كبلن السكي
الذي كان قائد للواء
جولاني والذي خاض معارك الشجاعيه عام 2014
حين قال الجيش اسرائيلي الان ولواء
الجولاني بالتحديد خسر ربع قواته وقال
خسرنا 82 ضابط في هذه المعارك بمعنى
ان معظم معظم ضباط وجنود الجيش الجيش
الاسرائيلي وخاصه من النخبه لواء الجولاني
يقتلون ونحن نعلم ان عدد قوات النخبه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا تتجاوز يعني 20 الى
30% من من الجيش الاسرائيلي فاذا ما كانت
هذه النسبه حتى الان قد خسروها انا اعتقد
انه كل يوم يمر ويخسر الجيش الاسرائيلي
وخاصه من قوات النخبه التي تقاتل الان في
خانيونس وفي الشجاعيه وفي الشمال سيكون
الموقف صعب و لدرجه انه هناك الان في
الداخل الاسرائيلي بعض الكتاب والباحثين
والمعلقين ينتقدون وزير الحرب وينتقدون
رئيس هيئه الاركان هليفي على على تصريحات
بالامس وقبلها حول الخسائر وحول الالم
وحول وحول الصعوبات والتعقيدات التي تواجه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وحجم الخسائر التي تلحق
به لانها تضر بمعنويات الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه وان دل هذا على شيء يدل على
ان لاول مره
يتعرض القاده العسكريون الذين يعتبرون
انفسهم انهم يقودون الجيش الذي لا يقهر
يتعرضون لهجمه من الداخل الاسرائيلي
يعلموهم يعلموهم كيف يصرحون كيف يخرجون
على الهواء وه هذه الانتقادات انا بتقديري
هي اكبر دليل على هزيمه الجيش الاسرائيلي
نفسيا ومعنويا وكيف تؤثر فيهم هذه الخسائر
وكيف تؤثر فيهم بساله وبطولات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه طيب لواء واصف ان حاولنا ان
نفهم الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب هل يكون
وصفه اصلا بالاستراتيجيه بالنظر للنمط
مستخدم في هذه العمليات سواء في العمليات
البريه او العمليات الجويه
المرافقه يعني اعتقد لاول مره وانا في
مواجهه هذا الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ العام
1965 لاول مره اشعر بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
فاقد فاقد لاي قيم عسكريه لاي خطط عسكريه
لاي قدرات اي في في في تنفيذ اي عمل عسكري
على الارض بدليل انه هناك 73 يوم و1000
جندي اسرائيلي هناك
80% من 100000 تقريبا هم من نخبه النخبه
لواء جبعتي لواء جولاني الوحدات الخاصه
لواء المظليين هم الذين يقودون الان
المعارك والذين يشتبك معهم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حيث ما تواجدوا حتى الان لم
يجدوا موط قدم لهم يرتكز عليه بمعنى لم
يسيطروا مازالوا في مرحله الكر والفر ما
زالوا في مرحله البحث عن اهداف ما زالوا
في مرحله يعني ال الاستطلاع بالقوه
العسكريه ومع كل ذلك يخرج لهم المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين ويشتبك معهم من مسافه صفر
ويحرمونا ويحرمهم من تحقيق اهدافهم او حتى
جمع معلومات حتى جمع المعلومات الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى الان غير قادر عليها لذلك
يلجؤون الى وسائل ضعيفه يلجؤون الى
المدنيين يركزون القصف على المستشفيات
يركزون القصف على الحياه حياه المدنيين
الفلسطينيين يريدون ان يقتلوا الحياه
ارادوا ان تكون غزه مقبره للفلسطينيين
ولكنها اصبحت مقبره للجنود الاسرائيليين
ومقبره لدبابات والياته هذه هي
استراتيجيتهم الجزئيه التي اشرت فيها ل
اليه جمع المعلومات والقدرات في هذا الصدد
تحديدا كيف نفهم بالفعل انه من ضمن
الاهداف التي وضعتها اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بهذه الحرب الانفاق استهداف القاده في
حماس
كذلك اخراج المحتجزين كل ذلك يحتاج جهد
استخباراتي وجمع معلومات واسرائيل تدعي
بانها تملك قدرات هائله في هذا
الصدد يعني لاحظنا ان ان هذه القدرات تبث
في افلام تمثيليه واضح انها تكذب على
انفسها حينما تقول انها وجدت نفقا على
حدود غلاف قطاع غزه بين ايرز وبين جباليه
بعد بعد 73 يوم والجيش الاسرائيلي موجود
في هذه المنطقه لم يكتشف هذا النفق الا
بالامس وهذا عند دل على شيء يدل على فشل
امني
واستخبارية تجاوز متر مربع ا هذه الافلام
التمثيليه تضعف ايضا من معنوياتهم لانها
لم تعد تنطلي على الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه حتى يعني هناك استهزاء هناك
استهزاء للجيش الاسرائيلي في اخراج مثل
هذه الافلام التضليلي يعني وانت تتحدث
لواء واصف نحن نعرض تلك الصور لهذا
الفيديو الذي نشره الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما
تحدث عن اكتشافه لنفق و وصفك لتلك الحفره
وحتى طريقه تعامل الجنود مع هذه الحفره من
الناحيه عسكريه وانت لواء عندما تكتشف ما
تقول انه نفق طريقه التعامل
ب توجيه عدد من الرصاصات باتجاه فوهه هذه
او فتحه هذا النفق و من ثم القاء قنبله
يدويه هل هذا هو التعامل الطبيعي في هكذا
الحالات بالتاكيد كلا اولا لا يوجد حرص لو
كان هناك فعلا مقاتل واحد لا ابادهم كلهم
حقيقه فلذلك لذلك يعني
مشاهد حركه حركه القدمين للجنود
الاسرائيليين مسكهم للسلاح محاوله القاء
القنبله اليدويه حتى حتى القنبله اليدويه
الجندي الاسرائيلي في في محاوله القائها
وفتحها كان واضح انه لا يعرف لا يعرف ان
يستخدم القنبله اليدويه وكيف كيف يتعامل
معها واضح جدا من خلال التصوير هذا كله
يعني اظهر بان الجيش الاسرائيلي ضعيف جدا
مقارنه مع الفيديوهات التي تنشرها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لانها حقيقيه حينما
تكون افلام حقيقيه تكون على ارض الواقع
بسلبياتها بايجابيات اما ان تنشئ فيلما
تمثيليا انا اعتقد كل سلبيات وكل يعني
مرئي ومعروف ومثبت امام العالم من رم الله
لواء واصف عرقات خبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك